Our public health system really is a disaster.
A hundred years ago, there was almost no chronic disease
over 20 years span. No increase in calories,
moderate increase in exercise.
And yet obesity rates 30% to 42%.
So there has to be something else in the environment.
It's in almost all processed foods.
They're being recommended by our public health authorities
in ever increasing amounts.
And with that has come this explosion of overweight,
obesity and chronic disease.
This science is not unknown,
it has just been silenced.
It's making us sick and people are not aware of it.
What we're being told to eat is at the heart of our problem.